so I think I was about 27 and I wrote it
as a short film just as a three-page
short it was just kind of the basic sci
fi idea of it and then it sat in a
drawer until after we made the brothers
bloom and ROM actually really liked the
short and always kept asking you where
is it yeah he actually went and pitched
the idea to looper looper to a bunch of
studios and they all actually the first
offer that we got was actually on looper
people who wanted to buy the movie but
we said no when this is not the movie
should do now I should go to bloom so
thank goodness yeah doesn't matter what
the budget you always have challenges
limitations so I think Ryan thrives on
the fact that he knows what he has to
work with and then he figures out a way
how to how to do it so we are very think
all of us we're very conscious of what
movie costs and we always wanted to make
movies for the right amount of money we
want you know we kind of figure out
ahead of ahead of you know ahead of time
what the value of the movies
internationally or domestically and we
going with back into that number and
figure out okay how can we make that
movie that Tehran is envisioning for
certain amount of money Joe and I are
we've become really really good friends
since we made brick and Joe it's just a
really unique situation where Joe is
he's a filmmaker himself and and our
collaboration is much different than the
typical director actor collaboration it
really does feel like to collaborate to
filmmakers collaborating because he just
knows the whole process and he brings
that knowledge to his you know his
performance on set he realizes he's
giving you pieces to put together into
an editing room he's very aware of that
and so he's very aware of the technical
end of it and so you know he still needs
everything he needs as an actor and it's
still about making really feeling the
moments and making them real at the same
time he's he has a filmmaking knowledge
you know so often you think you have to
and very often you have to kind of
quote-unquote trick kids into giving
performance and that was just not
case with Pierce Pierce Gagnon in this
name of the actor and he would act he
would sit down and he would be in the
scene he would be listening to the other
actor and responding to them and if
there was something that felt off you
would you know you would give him a note
and he would execute that note partway
in the scene and do the rest it was
ridiculous but I should say also because
in case everyone's everyone's worried he
also has a tremendous mother and he's a
totally normal five-year-old kid you
know I certainly thought we you know we
we needed somebody that just was older
to handle this you know this some amount
of dialogue he had and the kid was
amazing well the most challenging part
is definitely the right and grading
sucks writing is not fun writing is just
you know the toughest part and you're
alone and you're just sitting in the
room trying to make this thing work
wondering if it's ever going to work and
and and so that's definitely the the
toughest part I liked it when you told
me that you like to have written yeah
and unlike writing I like having ridden
it's like you know you're trying but
once you have written and once you hit
that idea or you've got that thing or it
clicks you have the finished script you
feel like this is the movie you know
there's nothing better than it in the
world so it's both the worst part and
the best part but you know it's been it
said much more articulately than I could
say that the writing process continues
all the way through the end of the
editing process and i would say in many
way you're finding the movie all the way
through bits really in the editing room
that you you truly find the movie and
that's where you also i in my and I this
is only my third film and still starting
out and figuring it out but in my
limited experience you know one thing
I've really found is that it's a it's
also the point where you have to let go
of your ego the most and you know you
have to let go of what your
preconception was especially as a writer
director at the movie that you had in
your head and you really have to find
what your footage wants to be you have
to find the movie that it wants to be
and it will it'll show you that if you
listen to it that sounds very ethereal
and odd that's really is true you have
to kind of go with what the where the
footage is taking you she's able to
internalize problems and then come up
with solutions which were his own
solutions and I think that that's you
know a huge that's about listening and
about you know
putting one's ego at the door it's just
being as honest as you possibly can to
in being as faithful as you possibly can
to the thing that's really driving you
to tell this story and for me it was the
human element of it so that was always
the the horse that was pulling the cart
and I think it yeah they would be
dangerous if you swap that around and
we're just looking to reference a bunch
of different time travel movies but for
this I had I had the theme I had in my
head I had something I really had in my
mind I had something I wanted to say I
had these characters that kind of grew
in my head they carried about and time
travel was a way of you know this engine
that kind of drove the whole thing